foreign
[Applause]
let's talk about pedophilia
it's one of the all-time great you know
pickup lines
so you know the whole Balenciaga story
they did a photo shoot with kids that
involved stuffed animals and bondage
gear I know what you're thinking hey who
hasn't
I mean Teddy Ruxpin and nipple clamps
seem like such a natural fit here's the
summary
the luxury fashion house Balenciaga is
in full damage control mode tonight amid
the big time backlash to its recent ad
campaign that appears to show children
holding teddy bears dressed in bondage
outfits and another of the kids near
supreme court documents on a child
pornography case that was the weird part
the whole child porn case thing so
Balenciaga went into crisis mode
throwing everyone else under the bus
until they realized there was a Bus full
of kids
hopelessly cornered they then apologized
but that's not what this monologue is
about it's about what really troubles
the left it's never the crime or the
criminal it's about when such incidents
force them to agree with conservatives
and they hate that they hate it more
than I hate flow from those Progressive
commercials that's a lot
well he dated back in the 90s and it
didn't work out
why do I have to keep seeing her but
they can't agree with the right because
then they lose their cachet so they
won't even if it puts them in a more
uncomfortable position than Rosie
O'Donnell in a hot yoga class
for example on The View which is the
show for people who sweatpants stick to
the sofa
the only Republican host they have says
the worst part of the ad wasn't the
actual sexualization of kids it's that
it gave the right evidence of the
sexualization of kids
there's growing anti-lgbtq sentiment
right now and it how it's Being Framed
is as portraying you know trans people
as groomers this is a terminal here on
the far right they're groomers this is
where you get the anti-drag queen stuff
that we're seeing so Balenciaga played
right into their hands by having kids in
a sexualized manner carrying something
that represents you know sex acts I
think it was a really bad misstep at a
moment where it's just kind of a
dangerous time to even give Credence to
those kind of insane takes it was a
misstep now that's the views only
Republican you know which is like being
the Manson family's only Republican
laughs
it's funny
because I repeated the same line so it's
not about the fashion company making
light a pedophilia it's the insane takes
about people making light of pedophilia
it's like saying you know it's not arson
that's bad it's those loud fire alarms
that lets you know it's happening
it's like the view would be happier if
they place the pedophilia somewhere less
conspicuous than an international ad
campaign out of sight out of mind but
you see this a lot unlike us the left
cannot condemn bad stuff no matter how
heinous it is if it forces them to agree
with a republican their brains can't
handle two different thoughts at the
same time or enjoy Reid's case one
yeah
hell some of them still say they're for
masking children do you know why they're
saying that because you're not
sure to pee it's my kids breathing and
stunts his growth mentally but agreeing
with Gutfeld will cause me to lose
friends and I also don't want him to get
any more popular than he already is as
if that's possible
it is ask yourself this why won't the
Dems or the media react in horror about
the crime wave because you and I already
have why won't they speak out against
the brutalities happening at the border
I mean other than the fact that they're
partly complicit in it because you and I
already spoke out against that stuff
so instead they freak out about migrants
flying to that hell hole that is
Martha's Vineyard forget about human
trafficking a Mexican wore white after
Labor Day
what about fentanyl it's killing a
hundred thousand people a year that
should upset somebody but it upsets you
so it can't upset them you know that
would be like watching it to Santa's
campaign ad and then Pelosi coming on at
the end and saying I approve this
message
right don't approve of those eyebrows
so you see the trend if there's a choice
to condemn evil they won't if they share
that opinion with you or me right now
using California's Mega Megan's Law
website the UK Daily Mail found that 7
000 convicted pedophiles in California
have been released from prison after
spending less than a year in jail this
after being convicted of lewd acts with
a child under 14. they're out and that
was just at a cookout Roman Polanski had
on Saturday
soon those curves will be back to their
old tricks producing Hollywood movies
[Laughter]
you don't have to laugh but you should
these are serious offenses no normal
human being can be okay with this stuff
so why are you only hearing about it
here on Fox News and nowhere else on
Legacy Media because it's guilt by
association if we report it they won't
me I don't care if we're right I just
want to make bad things stop and I don't
just mean kill Mead's haircuts
but if I thought I could get the Dems to
come out against riots or looting or
robbery arson murder I would come out
for it just to make it end
well that in looting does look a little
fun I mean free Sun Chips and men in
speed sticks I'm all over that huh
fact is
fact is because the media and the Dems
think we're evil actual evil things take
a backseat to their hatred for us if
tonight Tucker were to condemn arson
everyone in Hollywood would burn their
own homes down
it's because we're not part of their In
Crowd and I got to tell you I've never
been happier than to be on the outside
looking in in my whole life
[Applause]
tonight's guests
he's whiter than Hunter Biden's nostrils
Fox News contributor Tom shaloo
he gave me my start at Fox and tonight
he's here to apologize creator of red
eye and author of the new book The World
We Wish John Moody
he's Alaska's hottest export after whale
blubber and igloos actor writer and
comedian Jamie lissow
finally her favorite drink is the one
she gets to throw in your face Fox News
contributor Kat Tim
[Applause]
well not so well at the mountain 7 000
pedophiles yes that's a lot of
pedophiles I mean well that one is a lot
one is too many Greg yes seven thousand
that's seven thousand times one I know I
think there's only like 300 in and outs
in California yes
that means there's like dozens of
pedophiles in every in and out yeah
what that's incredible math I don't know
look they shouldn't release the
pedophiles hold stance yes but they
always release them and then they make
those uh you know the the sex offender
Registries I'm kind of against those
it's like just keep them in jail right
you know like the sex offense registry
is supposed to make you feel comfortable
it's like here's a map and I don't want
to buy them any gifts why wouldn't it's
not like when you buy a pedophile it's
true that they already I mean you know
what is it Crate and Barrel yeah
oh I get it right it's where they live
they make them register yes
but it doesn't come for me to see a map
with all the red dots on it and it's
like every one of those is a sex
offender it's like oh great I'll sleep
well tonight knowing that yeah just go
to the red dots and arrest them all and
put them back into jail yeah the only
people that sleep well on that chart are
the red dots that's so true we're gonna
applaud me Greg yeah
okay
Tom that was sad and desperate
and said John welcome to the show uh the
the creator of red eye you hired me uh
and um you therefore you worked in the
news business your whole life I was your
only mistake
do you agree with this kind of idea that
when Fox is on top of a serious story
the rest of the media will ignore it for
that reason alone yeah yeah Fox is just
so hated and and envied actually by
their competitors
um make no diff make no mistake the Fox
News division is very good and they do
their good work they check things out
they're right and they're first a lot of
the time I mean just think of Jennifer
Griffin down there at the Pentagon
um but it's the it's the Envy of our
success of your success uh that uh I
think just drive them crazy yeah and um
it's not going to stop it's only going
to deepen wouldn't it be easier for them
just to like you know agree that
something's really bad it's like they
can't like we've had this explosion of
crime we're going to talk about it later
in the show and it's like now they
waited till after an election to talk
about it but they know exactly what is
bad it's you yes and and you know it's
not going to change yeah you agree with
them on that well I I think that you're
a different kind of individual yes
foreign
yeah I I think it's safe to say that
when you hired me and then we did that
show you expected something different
than what I delivered
nobody knows what to expect at three
o'clock in the morning
and we got it yes
Jamie good to see you good to see you
you look great thank you yeah I'm
couldn't be more with you on the point
you were just making I thought if we
could if all sides could agree on one
thing it would be like children
shouldn't do dominatrix to stuffed
animals yeah but they somehow found a
way it's it's so it's just looking for
the argument I also think it's about
like she just wants to stay on there
make that money and stand that show yeah
agree with whoever she has to agree with
I will say and I know anybody out there
with a daughter that's like 10 or 11
like mine the ad is disgusting but my
daughter has done worse things to dolls
it's like every time I walk in it's like
she's auditioning for the bully from Toy
Story yeah a lot of dolls missing heads
at your house yeah it's a lot of
craziness also
I thought when Tom went on a limb and
said that they shouldn't have let out 7
000 pedophiles
um
didn't agree like
like not only do I don't I don't like
the word pedophile like I feel like the
word we use for them should be something
that like a kid could understand like
they should call them like bad man or
creep because you don't want to be like
hey Billy don't go across the street
that guy's a pedophile you know be like
oh my God I also love bicycles yes
speaking of bicycles that was a long
road to that joke
it is hard to make yeah it's hard to
make jokes about the files great and
especially and I'm trying not to use any
jokes for my new Netflix special
pedophiles murderers and other hilarious
things
is it already cast yeah yes
cat uh
how
it makes a good point and you would
think that maybe with an issue like this
the people in The View would actually be
more outraged by that than the actual
like oh we're feeding the cons or we're
uh that was so weird what she said
because she was like they shouldn't have
done this because you know the
Republicans they get really mad about
pedophilia
no second yeah like so saying
Republicans are the pedophiles or bad
parties like I think that's good yeah
yeah I don't think you're making this
point that you think you're making and I
I say this it shouldn't be hard right
because as everybody knows I'm extremely
I'm probably the most Pro drag queen
person on any network yeah I've never
said anything bad about a drag queen
because they fill me with joy and I
think they're wonderful and beautiful
that I'm not a drag queen right yes I
have a very similar daily routine to one
with all the extensions and the lashes
and the padded bra of course
um but you can just say this is gross
that there's this kid holding this
bondage teddy bear and there's this
pedophile documents in there and you
don't you don't have to think that hard
to say that that should be obvious and
you also feel bad for all those teddy
bears that are just into bondage
consensually with other adult teddy
bears yes that's true there's nothing
wrong with that either yeah don't kink
shame that yeah you don't you don't kink
shame the teddy bear yeah it is funny
though when you put it that way that it
was like the lady on The View didn't
realize she was complimenting the
Republicans you break it down remember
they really hate data files oh yeah
Republicans are gonna get really upset
about this pedophilia yeah yeah oh
all right we must move on I think we
really nailed that hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else